más menores con necesidad de asistencia
humanitaria que en cualquier otro
momento de la historia reciente así lo
alarmó unicef este lunes en su nuevo
informe un llamamiento para recoger
fondos y satisfacer las necesidades
humanitarias urgentes de más de 110
millones de infantes guerras brotes de
enfermedades desplazamientos hambrunas o
la crisis climáticas son algunos de los
factores responsables de esta emergencia
y Es que casi la mitad de los menores
del mundo viven en países con una
vulnerabilidad extrema a los impactos
climáticos estas crisis se
intensificarán a medida que el cambio
climático impacte en la frecuencia
intensidad y duración de las emergencias
profundizando las desigualdades en todo
el mundo y provocando nuevas oleadas de
conflictos desplazamientos y
enfermedades Además más de 400 millones
de infantes viven en zonas de conflicto
y 36,5 millones han sido desplazados de
sus hogares en América Latina 16,5
millones de niños niñas y adolescentes
requieren de estos fondos Y es que el
aumento de los flujos migratorios está
impactando en la niñez Esto es lo que
dijo a France 24 el asesor Regional de
la agencia de la ONU entre las razones
más importantes de este movimiento al
conflictos hay violencia en en América
Latina el tema de la violencia agudo
violencia urbana violencia en
comunidades es un factor importante para
que la familia decidan emprender viajes
muy peligrosos y hay situaciones
socioeconómicas muy complejas en parte
de vida todavía a la al covid a los
efectos del covid que han dejado una
crisis económica muy importante en
muchos países de la región agenda
humanitaria necesita 723 millones de
dólares para apoyar la respuesta a esta
crisis en la región latinoamericana y
garantizar a los menores que se cumplan
sus derechos básicos